Film Courage: We’ve heard screenwriters
use the phrase ‘Cracking The Story,’ so
what does this mean exactly?
Gary Goldstein: Cracking The Story is (just
to continue from what we were talking about)
you have the beginnings of a story but then
you beat out the story, you create the whole
story, you role out the carpet, basically
the whole story, so you don’t really crack
the story and it may be more of a TV term
than a film term (I’m not sure) but you
don’t crack the story until you are able
to tell the story from start to finish and
any of the holes in it are filled and that’s
my interpretation of it.
The concept of cracking something is like
“Oh!
That was what was missing.”
We got it and now we cracked the story and
the rest of it just falls into place.
So there’s that, but also just the concept
of being able to tell the story from start
to finish.
If I send in a pitch (let’s say) and I write
up a pitch to send into a producer or network
or something for a movie or TV show pilot
or something, I may send a premise line and
see if the general premise line is of interest.
And they may say “Oh, no.
We are already doing something like that.”
Or “That’s great, give me more.”
I will give them the story from start to finish.
It doesn’t have to be very long.
It can be a page and a half that I’m writing
but at least I’m not just giving them preamble.
I’m not just giving them the first act of
something.
I’m not just giving them like a tease.
I’m basically telling them, cracking that
story for them, telling them where that story
is going to go from start to finish.
Not necessarily in great detail.
Sometimes in more detail but it’s really
about being able to show that this is an entire
story.
This is where this will move and then we can
fill it in and amplify it as we go along.
So it’s really being able to tell a story
from start to finish, for me anyway.
That’s my interpretation of it.
Film Courage: What about those writers who
say sometimes they begin something without
knowing the ending?
Gary Goldstein: Well, I’ve done that.
Film Courage: Oh, you have?
Gary Goldstein: I’ve done that or where
the ending has changed a lot.
Again with April, May and June (this play),
I didn’t know.
I didn’t know what they were going to find.
I didn’t know that at the end of the first
act they were going to find…that the sisters
were going to find something, that it just
became obvious, it became the thing that was
driving me.
I didn’t even realize it.
And I didn’t know what that thing was going
to be until I thought about it.
So that was a case where I really didn’t
know.
I’ve definitely written things where if
you’re writing a romantic comedy, generally
the couple will get back together in the end.
There’s all of that, kind of some givens
but sometimes you don’t know.
Frankly, I do think it’s better to know
or at least have some idea.
It’s like getting in a car and saying “Well,
I know how to get halfway there but I don’t
really know where I’m going after that?”
You’re going to be stuck in the middle of
nowhere so it’s not dissimilar with a story.
I prefer to know where I was going and I think
certainly before you start sitting down and
writing it, you should have a pretty good
idea of where you’re going and if it does
evolve or it makes changes along the way,
great.
You know, work with it.
See where it takes you.
These stories unfold on your own sometimes.
But I think it’s helpful, like I said, I’m
a big believer in structure and having the
beats out before I start writing something
from start to finish but we can be surprised
and I bet there’s definitely been times
when I’ve not known exactly where I was
going until I got there.